an unparalleled design
long-lasting battery performance and an
innovative
autonomous system introducing
the apple car well our version of the
apple car
if you know a car could be made out of
iphone parts
apple's auto ambitions have been rumored
for years
and we still don't know if they'll come
to fruition but
what we do know is that from
self-driving capabilities to running
completely on battery power
cars are becoming more and more like
giant gadgets even if you're not driving
a tesla or new electric vehicle
there's a good chance your car is still
powered at least in part
by a computer so what's next in the
digital car revolution
today traditional auto companies need to
radically change how they do business
it's very different when you look at how
an electric and autonomous car is built
it is more like a computer on wheels
but what would it take to make a car
that's just as convenient and well
integrated as an iphone
and what parts does apple already have
experience engineering and producing
to answer that we had an idea crack open
an iphone and
build a car with the key automotive
parts tom forsythe a 3d artist from
london was up to the challenge
we shipped him a bunch of recycled
iphones and components he mocked up some
ideas and
we were cruising right along i would
thoroughly not recommend taking
apart iphones unless you're a trained
professional for it
because you may get cut you may set
things on fire in a very dramatic way
okay so not
everything in here is made of iphone
parts the wheels container for the seats
and some other parts are 3d printed
but most of it is iphone and yes this
was made in london
so the steering wheel is on the right
side of the car we tried to
use as many of the iphone parts as
possible we used the entire back
shell and all of the main components of
the iphone 11
to be the the kind of main undercarriage
and engine of the car as it were
while tom was building we spoke to
experts about the technology that's
going to be
core to the future of the car here's
what we put together
one of the most important parts of this
computer on wheels
the battery and the infrastructure to
charge it
apple knows a thing about batteries and
chargers okay fine the apple car won't
be charged via lightning port and
hopefully apple doesn't change the
connector every few years
but apple has spent decades improving
its battery performance in
everything from phones to laptops to
watches but
does that mean apple could just scale up
its batteries and put them in a car we
asked jennifer colgrove
an automotive analyst who spends a lot
of time talking with battery and car
companies
each battery sells steal the
fundamentally same chemistry as the cell
you are using on your phone
or your laptop computer they are the
fundamentally the same chemistry
but however when you pack a lot of the
batteries thousands of
sometimes even like even like tens of
thousands of cells together into a uv
battery
so that is dramatic most ev batteries
are made of some combination of lithium
ion and cobalt
both high demand materials apple's
familiar working with
but to make car batteries you'd need
more land to build a factory
more raw materials and a labor force
that knows how to build ev batteries
of course apple could outsource its
battery production much like it does now
with its iphone batteries
but apple is known for vertical
integration controlling as much of the
supply chain as possible
like with its chips and processors
another core
pun intended element to the
computerization of the car
apple has been making its own a series
chips for the iphone ipad and apple
watch for at least a decade
and in 2020 apple announced plans to end
its 15-year partnership with intel
to start making its own very powerful
chips for its mac
computers and we call it
m1 these sorts of chips can be used in
cars in a number of different ways
but they're specifically very important
to autonomous driving
explained armando perriera he brings
together tech and auto companies working
on self-driving cars
when we talk about computing we're
talking about
how can we squeeze all of this down to a
chip
that is powerful enough to run
everything in parallel
so you cannot steer now
and forget about the brakes or engine
control you have to do all these things
simultaneously
chips that power everything from
collision warnings to touch screens and
self-driving features
are in such high demand that car makers
have had to suspend production
and furlough tens of thousands of
workers over recent shortages
apple's new chip production sets itself
up as a major player amongst industry
giants like intel
qualcomm and nvidia of course there's
the chips that
do the data processing but just having a
chip in the car
isn't enough there's actually a massive
amount of software
that needs to be in place danny shapiro
leads marketing for nvidia's automotive
business
which makes chips and software to
process data for hundreds of car makers
today
including mercedes-benz toyota and
chinese eevee makers neo
xpeng and lee auto and so we've created
our whole platform it's called drive
and that is the heart of the car it's
really the brain of the car as well so
everything
plugs into this brain so you have
cameras that are looking forward or on
the sides or in the back
there's radar there's lidar which is
laser scanning so all
different senses nvidia's autonomous
drive platform is a decade in the making
and we don't know much about apple's
autonomous ambitions
but ceo tim cook said they were working
on autonomous systems a few years ago
we're focusing on autonomous systems and
clearly one purpose of autonomous
systems is self-driving cars
there are others a big part of
autonomous or self-driving technology
relies on cameras
radar and other sensors to analyze
what's going on around the car
a lot of the self-driving cars on
development today use lidar
or light detection and ranging
technology it's like radar but
instead of using radio waves it measures
distances using lasers
apple has lidar scanners or cameras
built into its ipad pro
and iphone 12 pro enabling augmented
reality features like
seeing how furniture would look in your
room before buying it
put that technology on a car and you get
a comprehensive look at the roads around
you
building a car is in many ways more
complicated than building an iphone
so even if apple has the component
knowledge why would it even want to
enter the auto industry
we asked gene monster an analyst that's
been covering apple for years
we spend a lot of time in cars and apple
wants to create products that
their mission is products that enrich
our lives and
a big part of our time is spent moving
around
plus apple has a history of
revolutionizing products
remember nokia phones or blackberries
and ipods
these are not three separate devices
this is one device and we are calling it
iphone
and the apple brand is already part of
the driving experience
carplay which brings key apple features
like maps music and messages to your
dashboard
has become a major selling point for
cars one survey found that 84 percent of
people aware of carplay
wanted to have this system in their next
vehicle
it wouldn't be too hard to imagine apple
using a large ipad size screen for the
dash of a car
that's running its own software and like
the ipad
and iphone cars are now increasingly
dependent on software updates
if our experiment of turning an iphone
into a car taught us anything
it was that it'd certainly be a massive
undertaking for the company
and despite having the cash and dna for
it that doesn't mean apple will speed in
by building the whole car
or even releasing an apple branded car a
lesson i learned a long time ago which
because apple's working on something
doesn't mean it's going to see the light
of day
i long prophesied that apple come out
with a tv and was
wrong apple doesn't comment on rumors
but
we can say with 100 certainty if there's
an apple car it will not look like this
and for now this might be the closest we
get to an apple car
you